what is the trashiest show in the entire
universe ken
mari povich 100 you knew that right off
the bat
it don't get trashier than this
and i'm here for it so we're gonna find
out the best of um if you're the father
or not have you seen these you must have
seen these this is the first one i think
i haven't seen oh okay well they're
beautiful let's just wait more i'm gonna
say this regardless if i'm the father or
not right i'm still gonna be in that
child's life
i don't believe him
neither does that dude look at him
that's the most obligatory i'm in the
audience clapped
the dna results are in look at it look
at that dude he's like
[Music]
um in the case of 10 month old royalty
daryl
you are not
is he happy is he sad oh she's running
[Applause]
hello are they trying to run away
but there's nowhere to run
oh it's so good
it's like what i think is going to
happen like maybe the test will be wrong
oh yeah it's your kid
it's just my turn
they will lie to the last second like
bro you're not getting out of this what
are you doing a quick word of a sponsor
nordvpn the greatest vpn of all time not
just because it has nord in the name and
i'm a nord as well but because it is the
greatest vpn it's fast it's reliable and
i think it's a little sexier than all
the other ones on the market but that's
just my opinion why should you use a vpn
well why should you care about
protecting yourself huh
protecting yourself from spyware
now with a new feature called threat
protection taking your cyber security to
the next level and you don't even have
to be connected to a vpn to use it it's
just a protection constantly keeping you
guarded shielded like the strongest
nordic viking shield it is actually
legit and it works really well another
great reason to use a vpn as you know
i'm in japan now i can still watch my
shows thank you nordvpn
with one simple click
i am back in england and now we can
watch lob island
thank you
it's risk free so if you want to check
it out for 30 days use the link in the
description and get money back guarantee
baby that's nordvpn.com pewdiepie check
it out it's worth trying out there's a
huge deal on a two-year plan where you
get discount and one month for free link
is in the description that's the way you
get the offer and thank you norviv for
sponsoring this video
it's the same thing every time let me
show you actually my favorite here we go
[Music]
oh
my dna results
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you can say it but i don't change the
dna
oh this poor kid just sitting back there
just waiting to know who her dad is it's
so
tasteless having the children in the
background like it's beyond terrible but
i love it
when it comes to three-year-old kanaya
michael you are not
oh they're dancing
dude
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dude look at the camera
the dude like trying to get the wires
and with the camera fell over and
everything oh it's good
chef case beautiful all right let's
check out some more michael you are not
wow
oh my god
oh
good i didn't see that
where are they running to where are they
going
[Applause]
that was the best scene i've seen i
forgot about that she [ __ ] ran around
[Applause]
little girls in the background like okay
well who is my dad i guess i'll never
know um
he was no baby daddy at all
[Applause]
[Music]
their stamina runs out very quickly in
this
it's like a horror game or something
that you just run a little bit you're
like oh god okay
oh my god
[Music]
oh the baby looks like he's about to cry
hazel is that live footage of the
children they probably have in the back
room somewhere oh my god oh i thought it
was like a video oh poor hazel you are
not
[Applause]
and in the case of 18 month old hazel
matthew you are not
[Applause]
where's he going i would love to be part
of the show and just like judge the [ __ ]
out of people i'm judging them right now
look look at the two dudes they thought
were the father oh my god
but like you could be the worst scumbag
in the audience and still be like oh
look at it
how could she
go please just go away yes in the case
of one-year-old kingston dez
you are not
do you ever see the one where the woman
is scared of uh olives the whole concept
of these shirts is making women run
backstage
what they do is they get people that
have phobias and they bring them on the
show and then they bring it out and show
it to them and let them freak out and
run away it's it's great
i mean isn't that how you're supposed to
get rid of your fears by confronting
them
yeah yeah that's the logic right they're
not just there to traumatize them right
yeah that's why you're scared
did he say we don't have any spiders
here yeah there's no spiders here
does it matter
you saw a spider on a tape and you went
nuts
the spiders are coming out
you okay
she's just wet she's looking she knows
you're okay with spiders yes i'm okay
well then
what bothers you me what why
why are you so afraid
i know there was a lizard in here
somewhere a lizard
a lizard
you're afraid of lizards
if i show you a picture of a lizard will
you get up
on the screen behind there dude
trust me bro do not look behind you
it's awful man
no i don't like that
just a picture
oh
bless sir
[Music]
oh it's not over he's not here he's not
here he's not here he's not here
he's nowhere
wait a second gwen wait a minute take it
off the screen please
producers be like oops
it's not over yet though because i bet
they do have one somewhere oh not the
lizards okay the picture is gone
gwen
that is so
mean
it is the meanest thing i've ever seen
and they do it a lot apparently that's
the whole format i bet he's just
pretending like it's not he's got
nothing to do with this it's what he
does like i don't have it it's okay it's
fine oh come on
they must know what they're signing up
for they do they get they get a sign up
for it all right here's the yeah this is
the olive lady right here uh olive lady
what's the matter
why did the window almost near me there
are no olives here he's like what see
and then
[Music]
my god you're holding onto my hand and
you're gonna pull it off
sally
sally
we're bringing out the olive sally
you signed up for this game 200 bucks
the olives will come whether you like it
or not can't even go down the aisle of a
depart of a grocery store
i mean all these are pretty gross i kind
of get that
[Music]
bring out the olives
it would be funny if they just brought
in like a one on a toothpick or
something they just brought up the big
gun oh it's so awful to laugh at because
she's obviously
traumatized it's all these
yeah i mean bring them out get the
olives yeah it's a genuine phobia like
you can't control it god damn jumbo size
olives here
they're not even pitted either
disgusting
are we bad people can't we're laughing
at me well they made the episode okay
we're just watching it all right right
yes yes
[Laughter]
[Applause]
a little over a year ago i had the worst
stomach ache of my life wait wait wait
it was just the corn dogs i have for
lunch but when i went to the bathroom to
relieve myself
a hand came out no shot oh shut up that
is the worst thing i've ever heard what
the hell
i thought of just some goddamn corn dogs
you know
i got that hand popped out
surprise it's a corndog baby but now let
me tell you what i really hope that my
lowlife idiot ex-boyfriend david is not
the father of my baby
my the editing is incredible just says
boyfriend corey on the other hand is a
great father
i don't know when i got pregnant but yes
i slept with both men around this they
look identical what the hell is the same
one dude i thought it was the same guy
it was like i swear his name was david a
second a different hairdo oh my god
okay oh she's got a type that in corn
dogs
right you don't get along with david do
you i cannot stand david he is a
low-life piece of scum that shouldn't
happen what did they even do
you're a liar
[Applause]
he's not there
you
[Laughter]
[Applause]
one the baby doesn't even look like you
no he doesn't it bernie
it looks like that other guy
we talked about that
you can't turn the hole into a
housewife everybody looks like
he can't prepare
gee geez
[Music]
oh we don't like david i'm confused all
right
well he's being mean to her oh okay
really yeah she's a hoe
she sleeps what are we doing in them
okay it's time to find out what
britney's current boyfriend corey has to
say everybody here's corey
yay
cory going to get him corey wants to be
the dad okay
oh no
you think you're the father i hope i am
in the quarry no six-month-old hope
dave's no hope for her you are not
the father okay good
good
that's good you should not be the six
month old hope
cory you are not
[Applause]
she found a third guy that looked
exactly like
him i mean they look like they're in the
audience honestly
look it's pete davidson right there
jumping
i am not surprised with this baby this
baby ain't got no answer puerto rican in
there this baby is the mexican as hell
this girl
[Music]
and i ain't one of them one guy tested
which means there could be 100 other
guys testing you in the audience you can
be the father
oh [ __ ]
oh god
i'll give you that everybody got three
kids i don't need another one
whatever man right stop show the results
right now what right now it's all to be
drunk on my mama's shoulder
he speaks like dave chappelle's like my
characters back in the day that's either
[Applause]
you know what's so funny you know what's
really so funny how you caught me last
night and told me not to come right now
what is he saying
[Applause]
i just want to talk to you jose
i can't deal there seems to be a pattern
of the more extroverted and crowded and
crazy you are the more likely you are to
be the parent responsible or the person
when it comes to one-year-old khalees
jose you are not
[Applause]
holy [ __ ]
that guy
that's on another level man
i can't wait the kid goes back when he's
older and watches
watches what his mom went through trying
to figure out who the dancer
oh god we are
lucky cat it could be worse man jesus
christ all right kate
what do you think about that episode hey
i think that was the best episode i've
ever seen ever and i'm i'm
not thinking i'm not the father they are
subscribed to this channel right here
[Music]
[Applause]
day